hey guys how's it going it's Justine
welcome back to my kitchen today we are
going to be making something very
festive for Halloween it's actually not
that festive now that I think about it
but they looked cool and I think it's
going to be pretty fun so basically for
these you're gonna need these massive
jumbo marshmallows you're gonna need
some little accessories you really can
do anything you want you want some
sprinkles get some sprinkles we've got
some sprinkles with little bones in them
we've got some of these little candy
corns and we've got some eyeballs so
basically we're gonna dipping these into
chocolate which it's not even chocolate
it's it's candy melts and then we're
going to decorate them the first thing
you want to do grab your little stick
got these on Amazon go figure
dip it in the chocolate whatever you
want to call it stick that in just like
so you know I think you want to go all
the way through just a little ways so
there's your marshmallow and then we're
going to dip them in here you might need
to fill it up a little more but I could
only get one thing of the black candy
melt so this is currently our situation
look at that you know what
now that I think about it in the picture
it wasn't completely covered not that it
matters you can do whatever you want
this is this is something you just use
your creativity you don't do whatever
you want this is a recipe developed for
all ages
I'll skill levels so now you're just
gonna decorate it for this one I'm gonna
put some eyeballs on it
oh is this pookie Oh
so says Pookie Wow so terrified not
gonna go to sleep tonight oh no the
rolling off god stupid we'll come back
to that one just
[Music]
okay we'll try again take your
marshmallow and dip it in the chocolate
it's not chocolate stick it in like so
and we're just gonna do a little bit of
it just maybe just just that yeah there
we go
there we go that looks awful okay we're
gonna cover the whole thing how do they
do it why do all the photos look good
it's a lie everything's a lie the
Internet is a lie everything you see is
not real
I'm not even here right now this is not
real then I'm gonna just sprinkle some
of these things on it that looks so nice
very spooky I'm terrified
[Music]
okay let's standing up
let's try no one this is really going
well
you know trying my best
sometimes your best isn't good enough
but don't let that discourage you or do
that's when you say yes I'll find
another job
like I don't see myself opening up a
bakery or a candy shop anytime soon this
is how we're gonna do it this is how
we're gonna do it there you go
do you want to have a Pinterest looking
Halloween Julia cause you can't we can't
do it here we can't you can't have that
here do you wanna have a Pinterest
Halloween no do you wanna pictures
Christmas no no we're not having that
none of that here
he hit it this is so dumb I was so
excited about it and really just did not
work out this is stupid
this was dumb where's my paper Jenna can
you hear me my paper I'm really
emotional right now
you've gotta go what's this to be fair
candy corns gross anyway so okay
it says repeat with remaining
marshmallows no it's a spoon the melted
candy on the sides immediately coat with
festive sprinkles immediately
immediately happy Halloween
see you guys tomorrow for whatever else
I happened to make I promise tomorrow's
will be better actually I can't promise
you that I can't promise you anything
don't promise things because then
usually this wasn't happen as you guys
later let me know if you guys try to
make these honestly I encourage it and
when they do look better than mine
please tweet me a photo because I would
love to see it happy Halloween happy
spooky snack week stupid snack week so
we're gonna make these super cool candy
eye pops as first you have to make a
cake and that is something that I can
handle of course we're gonna use a
blender so for our cake we're gonna need
the cake mix cake mix in oh gosh I
freaking love cake so much and goes our
1 cup of water 1/2 cup vegetable oil 1/2
cup
look at me ma